oh I I deserve some of the blame I I
made my farmscape too inviting okay this
is a mess what are we going to do now I
got you your blanket Mr goat no no no no
no no no we're going to wait for Santa
Claus by the chimy but it's
Thanksgiving what about Mr goat how come
I don't hear him anymore a Mr goat is
fine did you hear that what is it Mr
God he's saying that he needs some time
Alone look there's some cookies for
Santa here why don't you go and sit by
the chimney and wait
Santa hey look it it's not my place to
try to parent your kids good but one
thing we learned on the farm is the
death is a part of life if you tell Joe
what happened to that go death is going
to be part of your life okay you know
what kids can handle a lot more than you
think and every step from birth till the
end has its own magical Beauty so do we
Jam The Goat in the garbage or heave it
over the fence teach your children
[Music]
well